[Music]
next week marks 30 years since the end
of the deadly Waco standoff it started
when members of a fringe religious group
called The Branch Davidians opened fire
on federal agents now they were trying
to arrest a group's leader his name was
David koresh for stockpiling illegal
weapons at their compound 51 days later
that's how long this took 51 days on
April 19 1993 FBI agents pumped tear gas
into the compound to force a surrender
and the building caught fire
it ended this way 76 people died
including many many children a new
five-part drama series examines the
Fallout from that actor Giovanni Ribisi
I just like the name known for his roles
in Avatar and Saving Private Ryan plus
the defense attorney plays the defense
attorney rather for the surviving for
one of their surviving Branch Davidians
in this clip his character lays out his
defense plan
the issue can't be whether or not quresh
was the Messiah if that's our case then
they win
because guess what
he wasn't our case has to be about the
fact the United States government raided
these people's home without cause and it
was their overreach their hubris that
led to the deaths of 76 people including
17 children and in America you don't get
to do that because if they can do what
they did to our clients and get away
with it it'll give everyone with a badge
and a gun from a whacking hot security
guard to Janet Reno the authority to do
whatever they want to whomever they want
however they want we can't say you never
held together wow wow Waco the aftermath
debuts this weekend on Showtime part of
Paramount Global like CBS Giovanni
Ribisi joins us now first on CBS
mornings good morning good morning
welcome in Bravo to you thank you
another Stellar performance for you Mr
Murphy that's a really nice thanks but I
Envision this your agent calls and says
they're going to do a sequel to Waco and
you go yeah I want to do it I want to do
it how did it go well no it was actually
I had the first conversation with my
agent I said what do you mean there's a
sequel to Waco how could it's like
saying there's a sequel to the Titanic
it's like yes it's pretty definitive
what happened
um and then he said no no you got to
read this you got to read it so I read
it I read the the first episode and uh
really couldn't put it down and then I
couldn't stop talking about it and my my
partner my my girlfriend said at one
point well this is probably something
that if you're still talking about why
don't you do it yeah but did you have
trepidation about playing a lawyer yeah
I mean I never thought you it's really
my part in the show is a is a courtroom
drama and I never really really uh
thought I would be involved in something
like that just because I don't really
envisage myself as a lawyer or a defense
attorney or know anything about that and
also there was just it's just a massive
undertaking all the dialogue I mean
that's a you know anyways no but the
story was so shocking at the time do you
remember it Giovanni do you remember
seeing it as it was unfolding yeah
vaguely I mean I remember you know it
was 30 years ago I guess uh this week is
the the anniversary of the the last day
of The Siege and of course I mean it was
just something that you you just
couldn't believe it was uh just just in
insane and then and then fires started
happening happening it was just the most
tragic thing with with the children in
the building and all that so the defense
attorney you play was is a real life
person Dan cogdal yeah and how did you
feel not only about playing a real life
person but playing a person who as we
saw in that clip is making an argument
that was part of what seated the militia
movement in America helped Inspire
Timothy McVeigh sure yeah it is I mean
it's definitely a controversial subject
and you know it it it's there's a wide
divide there
um arguably Ruby Ridge and and Waco were
the seeds or the Sparks for the American
militia movement as we see it today and
that was part of one of the reasons why
I I thought it would be interesting to
to tackle this because when I was
reading the script
um I looked up and there were people
running down the street lighting things
on fire and and it just protest in this
country yeah and um and you know there
are echoes of that still 30 years 30
years later so you know uh the former
president Donald Trump uh held uh his
first official campaign rally in Waco uh
oh wow uh not that long ago I don't
think that was a coincidence you know he
said it was a it was equidistant from
Dallas and Austin uh it's uh not
convenient for a lot of people anyway uh
so there might be some symbolism there
there are other people who say you know
this anti-federal movement which your
character as a lawyer argues so so
beautifully and potently that's the key
point for people who are tuned into it
um they can draw a line from that to
January 6th yeah possibly and again I
think it's just it's it's it's almost uh
yeah it's again a spark to an overall
Zeitgeist of uh uh unrest and and sort
of I guess maybe perhaps certain parts
of the country being dissatisfied with
government overreach really
um and uh and yeah and I I don't think
that the show really uh has any pretense
towards either side of that it's just
more or less something that we should we
should we have an obligation to discuss
incredible it's amazing to go inside the
mindset yeah they showed mistakes on
both sides as I was watching yeah it's I
mean it's a tragedy across yeah across
the whole it's an incredible robe and
you've had incredible roles and I know
we got to wrap this up but I loved you
and Saving Private Ryan love you Boiler
Room love you and Lost in Translation
Avatar so this is just another feather
in your cap oh thank you cheers thank
you so much yeah got a lot of feathers
in that that's a lot of feathers well
thank you thank you very much continued
success Waco the aftermath begins
streaming this Friday on Showtime and
you can watch it air on air on Sundays
in real time